Every day when I wake up, I still can't believe I'm at Harvard.
Like every freshman, I get to live in Harvard Yard...
...and I get to eat breakfast in Annenberg Hall.
I really enjoy my freshman seminar "The Evolution of Aging."
It's just me, 15 other students and a faculty member.
And I get to work directly with my professor on research projects.
I'm able to visit any of the other great Harvard schools like the School of Engineering...
...or the Kennedy School where I've heard world leaders speak...
...or the medical school, which is pretty cool because I'm also training to become an EMT.
I wanna become a doctor.
Every day, I get to hang out with my friends and try something new.
Harvard is one university with a million things to explore...
...and I'm glad I've got the next three years to try them all.
My name is Anthony and I'm from Tucker, Georgia.